c'est un événement rarissime un
agriculteur du Québec voit sa carrière
récompenser ses jours-ci en devenant
membre de l'Ordre du Canada on rencontre
ce soir Gérard Trudeau et les présidents
des fermes Trudeau membres de l'or du
Canada donc bonsoir Monsieur Trudeau je
vais commencer par vous féliciter et
vous demander qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous le fait que vous
vous soyez maintenant membre de l'or du
Canada
et ça représente aussi pour moi
représenter le milieu agricole pour
laquelle où je suis né où j'ai grandi
dans Ça c'est une fierté pour l'ensemble
des agriculteurs du Québec du Canada
parce que je crois que rarement
quelqu'un a eu ça au niveau agricole et
puis
être capable de démontrer que
l'agriculture ça donne une grande
importance au Canada au Québec et ça
c'est ce qui m'anime ensuite très fier
de ça vous avez un parcours facilement
monsieur Trudeau est assez étonnant vous
avez été comptable malgré vous avez
directeur adjoint de la police de
Montréal le SPCUM à l'époque vous avez
élevé des veaux de lait exporter des
vaches en Italie et au Moyen-Orient
pourquoi autant d'expérience si
diversifiées
et je me disais on peut faire quelque
chose en vie puis notre amène soi-même
alors j'ai décidé mes parents étaient un
producteur laitier pourquoi qu'on pourra
pas exporter des bovins métiers à
pedigri à travers le monde et là
Monsieur intéressé à ça j'avais un
partenaire d'Italie et voilà on a lancé
ça à 71 pour laquelle il y avait presque
pas de facilité ça risque d'être
toute une aventure et je partais seul
par défaire se tourner un peu partout au
Moyen-Orient ou même en Europe donc ça
ça m'a donné de l'expérience et en plus
de ça la carrière d'en fonction publique
j'ai réuni tous ensemble et après en 19
on se dédie à l'agriculture mais en
particulier au fines herbes et c'est ça
aussi qui était complètement différent
c'était pas dans les façons de faire à
l'époque Monsieur Trudeau quand on était
cultivateur on se tournait plus vers les
céréales vers les légumes les fines
herbes ça n'existait pas au Québec à ce
moment-là
puis aussi en Italie on parlait de
basilique c'était ben important
et j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller dans une
école parce que je l'ai en Provence puis
après ça si je fais des pays scandinave
j'ai vu qu'il faisait ça la Boris
mais la chose qui est arrivée c'est dès
que j'ai commencé à faire ça au Québec
les fins d'alimentation qu'on
introduction on était les pionniers au
Canada à faire des pizzas alors
il me dit mais il faut pas que tu
arrêtes
faut continuer
puisque j'avais beaucoup d'expérience
dans la commerciale internationale il
faut l'international l'aviation j'étais
or qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va
trouver quel endroit
on a commencé à travailler un peu
partout comme ça parce que j'avais
l'intention avec ma famille de dire on
va où
consommateurs
on arrêtait de parler des épices mais on
va quand même vocabulaire pour aller au
final fonctionné parce qu'effectivement
c'est en fait c'est répandue maintenant
on les trouve partout vos produits et
d'ailleurs c'est toujours en belle
croissance l'entreprise vous avez de la
relève l'entreprise semble bien établie
vos petites filles entre autres vont
prendre la relève ce que vous avez des
conseils pour ceux qui se cherchent la
relève justement à titre d'entrepreneur
bon il faut faire confiance à cette
jeunesse voyez-vous ils vont à l'école
technologique
mais était avec les autres il voyait
très bien que il fallait apprendre pour
être capable de comprendre la question
des sols la gestion de
des insectes quoi que ce soit et donc
voyez que la plage fallait l'Institut
Technologique agricole et là par après
incorporer dans l'entreprise ça fait en
sorte que je dis
un futur donc on doit apprendre une de
mes petites filles me dit
c'est
un privilège mais voyez-vous
on est conscient que la relève
actuellement c'est pas très facile pas
très facile toutes les conditions
économiques le prix des fermes tout ça
et donc il faut y arriver l'autre jour
voyez-vous ils vont avoir un comprimé à
faire entre les sdans puis repreneurs
cette jeunesse qui est intéressée mais
est-ce que économiquement ils sont
capables c'est un beau défi mais je dis
souvent ça va un grand défi entre les
parents et les enfants qui est
déterminent les jeunes j'aimerais ça
faire maintenant quelques compromis tes
parents sont capables de faire
financièrement pour les aider à les
Verseaux
que ça c'est le défi des années
maintenant en fait il y a beaucoup de
choses qui ont changé depuis que vous
avez commencé en agriculture là je pense
à la technologie par exemple dans les
tracteurs il y a des drones aussi dont
on sert en agriculture c'était pas comme
ça à l'époque qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de tous ces changements là dans
votre métier
qu'est-ce que je ferais l'évolution ça a
toujours exister mais je disais mon
grand-père a traversé une période
difficile qui c'était la guerre en 1919
mon père c'était la guerre en 40 moi je
suis un fils de la guerre au fond et
vous savez on voit tous les femmes 50
ans il y avait rien presque on achetait
un agriculteur avec 25-30 000 dollars en
enfer aujourd'hui ce sont les millions
or il faut faire confiance que
l'évolution
ça fait partie du développement puis
cette évolution là les gens ne vont être
capable à faire sauf que comme j'ai dit
tantôt avec les compromis et la grande
communication entre les parents et les
enfants il faut qu'il soit clair pour
pas un moment je veux être la relève et
le dire puis ça prend vous savez c'est
long
au moins 7 ans pour préparer
les terres agricoles face aux acheteurs
étrangers par exemple
il faut le renseigner le renseigner que
aujourd'hui tu travailles avec des
grands entreprises il faut qu'ils
apprennent leur apprendre à négocier
avec ces grandes entreprises de foot
cela à peine le rouage donc il faut un
stage avec des gens avec qui sont vifs
et le transmettre notre connaissance aux
23 ma fierté pourquoi je suis très
dynamique madame encore à ça c'est parce
que j'ai le goût d'aider les jeunes à se
préparer pour affronter ce qui les
attend mais aujourd'hui on a technologie
ont beaucoup de choses que nous on
n'avait pas
mais vous avez l'avantage de
l'expérience et on sent encore toute
votre passion monsieur Trudeau c'est
déjà terminé malheureusement ça a été un
plaisir de vous recevoir ce soir merci
beaucoup pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI